alors moi me mettre à la couture adacore
donc ça y est on y est complètement
chiens
vaches il a couvert ces mares bah oui
absolument machines à coudre et donc je
tâtonne encore sur une écharpe s'est pas
loupé a tenus sur beaucoup de choses non
mais et donc oui matt albanaise a dû
changer de tenue d'abus ouais ça sera
comme ça une pub une tenue à chaque fois
oui j'en ai toujours un petit peu ou pas
on fait différemment d'accord et donc
oui la couture d'accord mais là il
continue à m'entraîner au jeu du
téléphone pour vraiment vous mettre une
petite fois d'accord si c'est ça votre
résolution de bain de sang vraiment on
voit qu'elle a aucun souci dans la drôle
à la résolution de
castaldi alors je le fais beau ça je
peux n'en est pas loin je pense à me
faire puis orchidées plaques' n'est pas
partir elle reste à faire pousser une
orchidée non
en fait c'est un lifting testiculaire
non
avec l'âge ça commence à se balader et
pris beaucoup de sport là mais l'arrêt
mais je vous lis lui j'ai vu la faillite
et toulouse il est arrivé ces coûts sont
arrivés deux minutes
[Rires]
le sud est
d'arriver à 9h barre des
libertines lifting pour avoir voilà pour
plus à se balancer
votre projet qu'on sera plus réussie que
les cieux
[Applaudissements]
réapparaissent et tourner dès mon
premier jeu maintenant je pense aller
sinon est ce donc c'est ce que vous
faites auriez vous pu accrocher une
ficelle et vous tous les
coups bas exactement assez de couilles à
trieste rouille
vous quel est vôtre est donné ce que tu
portes un ce type de contentieux web au
mas c'est bon c'est bon poser une
question moi j'en appellerai on
l'appelle pas aux buts à la pelle le
cochonnet merci ben moi j'ai rencontré
un mec qui me plaît bien et vous étiez
pas le cas avec vous si mais c'est fini
c'est terminé c'est chez moi ça va très
bien ça va ça vient marion
est en fait je vais proposer de jouer au
scrabble ouais voilà et parce que je
pensais être très doué os crânien
fatigue de la mine depuis donc il faut
que je joue il faut que je m'améliore
faisait rien d'autre à [ __ ] jour 2
avec lui ouais pour l'instant non pour
l'instant joué en sélection mais vous
savez que personne ne vous croira je
vous assure ah ouais on fait des scram
pour le moment l'heure à oued accord une
technique de ces qui leur a fait beau
bref ça
[Applaudissements]
mais doit pas tout frais pour arriver au
quatrième rendez vous sur un scrabble
non mais justement c'est bien
mais à un moment il faut que ça monte à
que les iraniens donc c'est l'adresse du
garage et il agit non il n'est pas âgé
pourquoi non mais sert plus de 50 un peu
plus de 50 un peu plus un petit peu on
est on est dans le 50 de près ces
castaldi c'est à 50 il va faire un
lifting curieux
j'ai su papa de gym urbain est gentil et
d'isabelle ah oui isabelle parce que
j'étais méchant et les dernières même
quand elle dit n'importe quoi tu pourras
dire tout ce que tu veux je ne crierai
plus voilà je laisse la distance est une
très bonne résolution oui ce fou mais
c'est une très belle merci oui et notre
évolution dont tout le monde se fout des
positions
dures et dure et ne pas vous couper la
parole wen quand vous ne passez pas la
parole c'est beau et puis vous
convaincre enfin devenir badminton pas
s'ils finissent par croire à la
fédération que je vous connais pas en
fait si bien que ça je leur
conseillerais
[Rires]
faudrait
déjà c'est le retour des mois
maryse a
aplani par trois connaissent en direct à
la mer noire
vous êtes gentil
moi j'ai pris la décision de faire ce
film
on ait péché je sais pas quoi
non mais il est complètement tari ce
métal alors baptisé hutus alors ben moi
j'étais au sixième avec les autres
chroniqueurs là où il ya une salle aussi
dit oui ce qu'ils voulaient faire du
théâtre est mort à tous à erika moulet
on est tous là tu embrasses rachid arhab
attend un coup de fil à midi
alors et donc alors oui donc quitter ou
non non non mais c'est quoi ta
résolution alors ma résolution c'est de
reprendre le foot à 45 ans a reçu une
licence dans un club et tout je vais
faire deux entraînements il veut rejouer
c'est le club compris goléo quoi il y en
a deux il ya des mecs libre sur le
marché la cmb depuis le 3 janvier et moi
alors libre vous allez avoir beaucoup
mon appel
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
obligeant le pouvoir comment voulez-vous
prendre comme ça
c'est quoi le club vous allez jouer ah
bah faut le trouver
des mois mais qui a un club qui reprend
un gars de 90 kg faut que je m'entraîne
belle cyril fait qu un niveau non mais
attendez pour ce qui a trait à 90 qui
vous vous avez un club je peux trouver
non ça maintenant
vous savez je suis pas venir moi quand
je vous rends je vais pas jouer autant
là je peux venir gratuit je m'en fou
rigole mais a bien sûr mais bien vous
allez perdre quelques kilos vous avez
gardé comme ça au moins 10 ans perd
brice g vient le nom donné aux
descendants à 80 82 j'ai vu guillaume là
on va mettre un truc en place beaucoup
plus vite si on fait des années qu'ils
voulaient mettre un peu
au salarié mis en place du tout cas ce
chef qui est beaucoup moins prononcée
que d'habitude [ __ ] j'ai su rester à
paris c'est la merde bah oui parce que
personne n'a envie d
[Rires]
le monde
markham on le dit d'ailleurs c'était de
prix d'avril profite d'un ces cas-là de
monter tous les tarifs à dublin c'est
pas pareil laverda ce qua non moi je
vais essayer ma résolution de
2,2 essayer de dire de phrases sans me
tromper dans cette émission aurait que
vous avez est excellent en 2020 c'est
vrai même a dit le savoyard h la gueule
tu as été une vraie merde en 2021 est
anormal en fonction il avait
d'excellents 2021 jean verdier en 2022
je suis bouleversée et je suis sûr ça va
vous c'est gentil c'est bien un peu
dépressif là pas du tout c'est vrai mais
c'était quand même bizarre pour moi ça
faisait plus de 25 ans qu'on n'avait pas
j'étais pas rester à paris bonne c'est
fait après les photos coquines a pas été
en vacances ceux payés par l'état
non mais c'est vrai c'est bizarre j'ai
beaucoup apprécié dans l'année dormir
tranquille pas avoir de soucis rien
quand il ne s'est pas tu te prends le
dromadaire au curry
et par des bourses et moi non mais
c'était curieux mais c'était très
agréable finalement merci alors il nous
revient tout droit de il détecte maps et
ce qui
est parmi les badauds s'amassent non non
j'ai fait des ulis m'attend alors
d'accord et à mon avis c'est quoi vous
avez mal passé la machine
[Rires]
il est blanc comme en q1 j'ai fait une
cabine faciale franchement on dira à nos
rayons
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ah
ouais mais je voudrais dire à nos routes
colas blanc mais ça non mais c'est vrai
non mais ça nous va très bien vous cette
préposée du front ses fans cabine
faciale en fait tu as i l est mais ils
on faisait pas pris la non demande et
vous êtes malgré tout j'ai pris une
grande résolution sentimentale j'ai
décidé d'arrêter de papillonner de me
concentrer sur une personne alors c'est
la gueule non
alors elle me connaît pas encore ah je
les ai vus à la télé en fait pendant les
vacances et je les vis et je sens qu'on
n'est pas à l'abri de voler avec les tas
d'histoires non elle présente des
émissions sur tf1 et on n'est pas à
l'abri d'une belle histoire karine ferri
karine ferri non
mais oui en fait j'ai regardé le
bêtisier mais le cours le 31 je sentais
qu'il s'est passé une belle soirée
mais je sentais qu'il y avait un lien de
prix déjà les médias gamin mais avait un
truc qui se passait les 20 jeux de
regards qui s'est installé comme à la
télé ouais ça va vous sinon
ap ap la police locale
[Applaudissements]
on
peut découvrir avec appelé les autorités
à nous il
n'y a que moi qui vous ai vu chanter
mais 8 a été bien rediffusion oui ma
cervelle on a fait pas mal d'audience
était bien bas merci isabelle merci vous
faites une très
jolie